elena volochine merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes notre correspondante à moscou
pour france 24 et vous êtes à moscou
depuis plus de dix ans comment d'abord
les russes sont informés de ce qui se
passe en ce moment alors il ya une
partie de la population qui regarde
toujours les chaînes de télévision
d'état on a du mal à évaluer à évaluer
combien encore sont vraiment assidus
dans l'eure dans leur suivi du conflit
sur les chaînes d'état depuis 2014 mais
en tout cas cette partie là elle adhère
complètement à la réalité parallèle
qu'écrit bladimir poutine à son discours
de dénazification démilitarisation de
défense des populations civiles etc
ensuite il y a peut-être la majorité
silencieuse ou bien la minorité
silencieuse encore une fois c'est
difficile d'évaluer l'opinion de gens
qui sont lassés de ce conflit puisque ça
fait sept ans et demi un que qu'il dure
et donc et donc cela il ne regarde juste
plus les chaînes d'information qu'elle
soit d'état ou qu'elle soit alternative
et ensuite il y a cette partie de la
population russe progressiste qui a
voyagé un accident qui elle suivait les
médias d'opposition puisqu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de média neutre en russie on
est soit dans un camp soit dans l'autre
dans ce genre de régime autoritaire et
donc cela il se voit privé depuis depuis
l'invasion depuis le début cette
agression de plus en plus de leurs
moyens d'information puisque on voit
qu'au fur et à mesure du durcissement du
conflit et du durcissement notamment
avec l'occident et bien la russie est en
train de se fermer en train de fermer
les médias indépendants ça a commencé
avec la fermeture de la chaîne
historique d'opposition au doj qui était
avant une chaîne de télévision qui est
devenue une web télévision donc il ya
quelques années déjà qui a subi la
censure ensuite la fermeture de la radio
indépendante d'opposition echo de moscou
qui pourtant a été dirigée par par
alexei venediktov qui avait largement
ses entrées au kremlin et là pas plus
tard qu'aujourd'hui et bien les sites
web de la bbc de voice of america 2 mai
12 ha de plusieurs médias indépendants
et bien on était ont été éteints et
classé pour ce qui est de la bbc sur la
liste des sites qui appelle à
l'extrémisme aux désordres de masse et
aux appels illicite à rassemblement et
ça c'est la première fois que je voyais
que je vois ça c'est à dire qu'on
connaissait la liste par exemple des
agents de l'étranger où il avait des
dizaines de d'organiser à sion et de
médias qui étaient inclus depuis
plusieurs années mais c'est la première
fois que je vois cette liste de sites
qui appelle à l'extrémisme donc voilà il
ya des nouvelles mesures est très
important de mentionner la loi sur les
fesses news pour ce qu'il y ait des
actions militaires qui a été adoptée
aujourd'hui à l'unanimité par par la
douce à ela qui rend passible de 15 ans
de prison tout message qui est considéré
comme étant mensongers sur sur les
actions de l'armée russe mais les russes
ils ont accès par exemple à internet les
rues sont encore accès internet mais il
met à moins d'avoir un vpn ils vont pas
pouvoir ouvrir les sites les sites
d'information principale principaux
sites d'information alternatif est-ce
qu'on a une idée de comment évolue
l'opinion russe est ce que par exemple
ils sont informés des soldats tout
d'être né ce qu'on parle des soldats
tués ou pas
alors les soldats tués ces deux émirs
poutine qui en a parlé hier parce que ça
circule parce que en dehors des sites
d'information il ya aussi tous les
tchats télégramme par exemple qui sont
devenus de véritables sources d'infos et
chaînes d'info 1 pour les russes qui
avaient de plus en plus de mal à
s'informer ceux qui cherchent justement
cette vision alternative donc il y à des
chaînes télégramme et dans ces chaînes
télégramme et bien envoyé beaucoup de
vidéos de témoignages de soldats de
familles de soldats qui sur les pertes
que subissait la russie donc ça à un
moment donné ça ne peut pas faire
l'objet d'un black out total et d'un
secret total dont platini à poutine il a
parlé hier l'armée russe a donné un
chiffre 500 soldats morts on suppose
qu'il est largement en dessous donc et
vladimir poutine immédiatement de parler
de deux héros kiss kiss qui sont mort
héroïque mois en ukraine pour pour le
bien pour la défense des populations
civiles etc et de promettre des
compensations à hauteur de plusieurs
millions de roubles aux familles donc il
y avait il est ce message sur les pertes
mais toujours ce message de sans dire
qu'on est en guerre qu'on mène une perte
opérationnelle du tertiaire le mot
guerre est banni du chant informationnel
russe s'est interdit maintenant c'est
passible de cette fameuse loi sur les
faits que nous donc voilà le l'état en
ce moment le monopole sur le message
militaire et sur la sur la vérité entre
guillemets de ce qui est en train de se
passer donc les voix dissidentes elle
n'arrive plus à se faire entendre non et
le problème des journalistes aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on n'a aucun baromètre on n'a
aucun point de repère pour savoir qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire ou qu'est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas dire on nous disent qu'on ne
peut pas dire mais on s'est dit mais
peut-être en fait on peut quand même le
dire mais est-ce qu'on va aller en
prison pour ça est ce qu'on va prendre
trois ans pour pour un fait simple de
mensonges ou 15 ans parce qu on nous
dira que notre mensonge aura été
prémédité c'est vraiment les différents
paliers de cette loin sur les faits que
nous donc ça c'est très compliqué parce
que
la garantie disons du travail des
journalistes en notamment des
correspondants de presse étrangère
jusqu'à présent et c'était un peu le
dernier bastion de liberté d'expression
ne subissait pas vraiment la censure
malgré des conditions de travail
difficiles la garantie de notre travail
et l accréditation délivrée par le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
ces derniers jours depuis le début de la
guerre le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères a bloqué quasiment je n'ai
pas d'informations s'il ya eu quelques
accusations délivrée mais de ce que je
sais toutes les demandes d'accréditation
qui ont été sollicités ont été refusées
donc on a on ne peut plus se fier à cet
écrit citation on ne peut pas se fier à
notre liberté de parole et à ce qu'on
sait de la vérité de ce qu'on a envie de
dire de la vérité parce qu'on risque de
tomber sous le coup de ces lois et donc
on est obligé de se dire est ce que je
peux publier un article où je vais
employer le mot guerre est ce que je
peux est-ce que je vais risque et la
déportation est ce que je vais risquer
la prison là en ce moment à moscou les
journalistes de façon générale sont un
petit peu perdues par rapport à qu'est
ce qu'il peut faire avec tout ça et
quelle est leur marge de manoeuvre et
vous pensez que c'est possible
d'accentuer da par des occidentaux ou
des médias indépendants la prise de
distance entre les russes et bladimir
poutine
je pense que la prise de distance elle
portera les russes et vladimir pour lui
je pense que
le la faille dans l'adhésion à ce
discours adhésion toute relative parce
qu'elle est sans doute de surface et que
les gens par peur souvent ne disent pas
ce qu'il pense je pense que la faille
peut intervenir à partir du moment où la
russie va entrer dans cet isolement dans
va subir les conséquences des sanctions
parce qu'on a toujours dit que en russie
si révolution il y aurait ce ne serait
pas une révolution des idées mais une
révolution du frigo donc les gens qui
sentent que leurs conditions de vie
deviennent difficiles que que ça a des
conséquences pour eux directement là il
y a une possibilité de début de
rébellion rébellion maintenant on voit
que la répression est en train de se
durcir tellement on est en train de
basculer quasiment dans une dans une
dictature en russie en ce moment un d'un
régime autoritaire donc qu'elle les
quelques personnes qui essaient de
manifester sont arrêtées six fins et de
plus en plus difficile moi j'ai donc je
ne
on va avoir du mal à mesurer en fait
c'est ce ralentissement de l'adhésion
parce que les gens tout simplement
auront peur de s'exprimer merci beaucoup
elena volochine d'être venu merci pour
votre analyse